字幕: Paul Alduncin
校正: Moe Shoji
「私には難しい」
そう思って やりたいことを
諦めた経験はありませんか？
私は今 中東のヨルダンという
日本人がほとんどいない異国の地で
一人起業をしています
海外で起業というと
多分大胆さとか勇気とか
こんなことを兼ね備えた
いわゆるすごい人がやることなんだと
イメージするんじゃないでしょうか
私も電話を１本かけるにも
ものすごく緊張しちゃうし
大学院までは 世の中で良いとされるルートを
たどってきた人間です
だから私にとっても
起業をするっていうのは
例えば リーダーシップとか発信力とか
人望とかそんなことを兼ね備えている
いわゆる並外れた能力の持ち主
というイメージがありました
私にとっても
ずっと程遠い存在だったのです
ただ 私にはやりたいことが一つありました
それは 中東の難民の人たちに
仕事を作るということでした
そして私は そんな夢を
ずっと５年間持ち続けていました
なんでそんな思いを持ったのか
少しお話しさせていただければと思います
きっかけは 高校２年生と
大学４年生の時でした
高校２年生のとき 私は１年間
フランスに留学をしていました
そのとき 私はフランスというと
パリのおしゃれなイメージだとか
フランス人の格好いいイメージを
想像していたんですけども
実際に 現地に行って
現地の高校に通って
現地の家庭で暮らしてみると
実は アフリカや中東からの
移民の人たちというのが
たくさん住んでいることがわかりました
そしてその移民の人たちと
その子供たちというのは
社会的にも経済的にも
厳しい環境で暮らしている人が
たくさんいるということがわかりました
彼らが住んでいる地区には
窓ガラスが割れていたりとか
落書きがされているような建物が
たくさんありました
私は それを見た時に
私が生きていた環境は
家族にも 友人にも 囲まれていて
経済的にもかなり恵まれた生活を
してきたんだなということを感じました
そしてずっと先進国だと思っていた
フランスでの経験は
とても私にはショックでした
「もしかすると 世界には
ただそこに生まれたというだけで
苦しんでいる人たちが
たくさんいるのかもしれない」
そんなことを
私は考えるようになりました
そして「私は偶然恵まれた環境に
生まれたんだから
次は 私が社会に対して
恩返しをしていく番だ」
そんな風に考えるようになりました
帰国した後 私は国際協力という
世界の貧困問題とか
環境問題に取り組む仕事が
あることを知りました
そしてそんな仕事を
私は目指すようになったのです
そして 大学４年生の夏休みのとき
私は初めて 中東のヨルダンに渡航しました
その時のヨルダンには
シリアの紛争が始まったばかりだったので
紛争によって命を守ろうと逃げてきた人たち
というのがたくさん住んでいました
そして 私は一人の難民の女性と
会うことがありました
彼女は 紛争によって
旦那さんを亡くして 家を空爆されて
そして着の身着のまま 歩いて
ヨルダンに逃げてきたような人でした
そして彼女は ヨルダンでも
仕事を見つけることができなくて
この後 どうやって
暮らしていけばいいかわからない
そんなことを私に話してくれました
そして私も 何かできることがないか
そのとき考えたのですが
私はそのとき彼女の話を聞くことだけで
どんなこともすることができませんでした
それが悔しかったのを覚えています
何か動かなければ
私も彼女たちに仕事を作らなければ
そう思ったのですが
私にはそのとき 起業をすぐに始める
という勇気がありませんでした
そして 私は異国で支援をするにも
まずは何か私がスキルを
身につけないと
そのように考えるようになりました
だから私は 一番自分が成長できる
社会貢献を行っているスタートアップ企業に
就職することにしました
そして初めて 入社した会社では
私の周りには 志もあって
やり遂げる力もあって
心から尊敬できるような
起業家の先輩達がたくさんいました
そんな周りの人たちと比べて
毎日毎日 私は自分ができないことに
目が向くようになりました
どうやったら
もっとできるようになるだろうか
周りの人に近づけるのだろうか
そんなことを考えているうちに
「私って一体何の取り柄があるんだろう」と
考えるようになりました
毎日毎日 自分の悪い面と
向き合っているうちに
自分の良いところがまったく
見えなくなってきたのです
そして 私は「周りの人と比べて
優れているところがないのであれば
私は起業家には向いてないかもしれない」
そんな風に考えるようになりました
そして私が出した結論は
ずっとやりたかったと思ってた
起業をやめることでした
そんなときに 会社の上司が
言ってくれた言葉があります
「いいか
君がヨルダンで
事業を起こすということが
社会にとって損失になるって
いうことを考えたほうがいい」
私はその言葉に はっとしました
もしかすると私は 周りの人みたいに
上手くはできないかもしれない
だけど 私がやったら
１か100かの結果を残す可能性がある
そして私が何もやらなかったら
結果はずっとゼロだということ
それと同時に
今この瞬間も 難民の人たちというのは
ずっと苦しんでいるんだということを
思い出しました
私が今日どんなことをしようが
あの頃と難民の人たちの状況は
ほとんど変わっていないのです
上司の言葉が私を動かしました
「一刻も早く
彼女たちに仕事を作らないと」
そう思うようになりました
さて 私は起業すると決めた後
一体どんな起業家になろうかと悩みました
そこで周りの起業家や
世の中の起業家というのを注目してみると
本当にいろんな人がいる
ということがわかりました
起業家といっても 得意分野は
それぞれ異なるのです
人を集めるのが得意な人もいれば
コツコツコツコツ毎日努力するのが
得意な人もいました
そして私が気づいたのは
起業家には正解はないということです
どんな人たちでも
起業するような力はある
だけど どんな起業家になるかが違うだけ
それに気づいたときに
「私は私らしい姿で起業家になろう」と
そう思うようになりました
そして この話は他の職業にも
言えることなんです
デザイナーは絵が上手くなきゃいけない
お医者さんは頭が良くなきゃいけない
本当にそうでしょうか？
絵が上手く描けなくても
色使いが上手いデザイナーさんもいます
成績が良くなくても患者さんに
寄り添える優しいお医者さんがいます
だから やりたいことがあったら
自分に足りないところばかり
見るのではなくて
自分らしく実現する方法っていうのを
考えてみてください
それが 世間一般で言われているような言葉に
惑わされないようにしてください
どんなことでも自分らしく
実現する方法はあるんです
それが一般的な形じゃなくていいんです
自分らしい形を
作っていけばいいのだから
そして行動してみることで
やっと気づくことだってあるんです
「ああもっとこんなスキルが欲しいな」とか
「思ったよりそんなに楽しくなかったな」って
こともあると思います
でもそんなことはすべて
やる前には見えなかったような景色なのです
私は 自分で起業してみて
一番うれしかったのは
私の「やりたい」という思いに対して
応援してくれる人たちの存在でした
一人で考えていた時には
全然気づかなかったのですが
純粋な「やりたい」という思いに
共感してくれる人というのは必ずいます
それも立ち止まっていた私には
全然わかりませんでした
今日 皆さんにお伝えしたいことは２つです
一つは やらないうちは
何の結果も生まないということです
それがあなたに向いているのか
向いていないのか
そんなことも やらないうちはわかりません
結果を生んでいないのに
判断するのは早すぎます
少しでいいんです
試してみてください
そして２つ目は
「自分には無理」と思うことでも
必ずあなたらしく
実現する方法はあるということ
誰でも個性があります
得意不得意があります
そしてどんなことでもやり方は
一つじゃなくて
いろんなやり方があるのです
やりたいことがあるのであれば
あなたらしい方法で
どうやって実現させるのか
そういう風に考えてみてください
あなたの純粋な「挑戦したい」っていう
思いには応援してくれる人が必ずいます
最初は一人ぼっちの挑戦に思えても
あなたの「やりたい」という思いを
言葉にして広めていくうちに
必ず それに共感してくれる仲間が出てきます
そして 一歩踏み出す決意をしたら
心はすごく軽くなると思います
今 この瞬間に
一歩 あなたらしい一歩を
踏み出す決意をしたのであれば
私が一番最初の応援者になります
今日はありがとうございました
（拍手）